[Music]
welcome back to this special edition of
Hannity now according to multiple news
outlets tonight a highly anticipated
report from the Department of Justice
Inspector General is expected to
criticize former FBI deputy director
Andrew McCabe for authorizing improper
media leaks about an investigation into
the Clinton Foundation back in October
of 2016
this same IG report is also expected to
get into the Clinton email investigation
this news comes on the same week that
more than a dozen Republican lawmakers
in the House sent a letter to Attorney
General Jeff Sessions urging him to
appoint a second special counsel to
investigate both the FBI and the
Department of Justice's handling of the
Clinton and Trump Russia probes Florida
congressman Matt gates is one of the
lawmakers calling for a special counsel
a second special counsel he joins us now
or a good evening congressman good
evening judge all right now you are
renewing as our many Republican
congressman the request for a second
special counsel now I imagine that most
viewers are saying they did it before
why should it happen now and what's new
that they're asking for it again well
judge the last time we spoke about the
ability for Democrats to convert
political cash into a government
sponsored warrant to spy on members of
the Trump transition team you said you
wanted to see people led away in
handcuffs
not just fired but led away in handcuffs
well you know what the FBI and the
Department of Justice aren't going to be
putting the handcuffs on themselves so
we need a second special counsel just as
congressman Lee Zeldin has recommended
so that we can take the findings of the
IG report we could take the information
we've learned in congressional hearings
and we can actually have prosecutions
because my fear is that if we don't have
a second special counsel this will turn
out a lot like the Benghazi
investigation where we learn a lot of
facts but no one's really held
accountable you know what bothers me
congressman is that given the the FBI
and the Department of Justice is
dilatory approach you know to everything
from the handing over of emails from the
redactions from
the outright refusal by even the FBI
director saying well we'll work out what
we're going to give Congress which has
oversight over justice and the FBI
you know it seems to me that they it is
impossible they basically said
everything but we dare you because we're
not gonna do anything anyway what do we
do about this
well Congress doesn't have the power to
throw people in jail but we have the
responsibility to find the evidence and
show it to the American people and to
your point judge Jeanine if we had not
had congressional oversight and hearings
and subpoenas we wouldn't even know
about the text messages between Pete's
truck and Lisa page that demonstrate a
substantial anti-trump Pro Hillary bias
you mentioned Andrew McCabe earlier his
testimony before the Judiciary Committee
in closed session showed me that Hillary
Clinton was never really put in jeopardy
as a result of her use of a private
email server and the leaking of
classified information because she had
people that were running interference
for her at the DOJ what do you say to
people who say I am so sick and tired of
this Clinton email investigation thing
let it go what do you say to them well
we cannot live in a country where losing
an election function functions as a de
facto immunity deal if people broke the
law they have to be held accountable
because if we just allow that to happen
then we invite that type of crime in the
future that's why the rule of law
matters and now the Clintons they've got
decades of ignoring the rule of law
never being held accountable and we've
got a chance to change it and we should
take that off soon what are the chances
of getting a special counsel a second
special counsel well that is up to Jeff
sessions and frankly took himself off
within 24-48 hours of being appointed
the Attorney General he tells the
president I'm recusing myself I mean if
this is beyond the pale Jeff Sessions is
not going to do it Jeff Sessions says
I'm getting an inspector general oh we
can spend another year and a half on an
Inspector General coming up with a
conclusion the Inspector General doesn't
have the right to go to a grand jury
subpoena anybody so what's and what is
this guy doing well if Jeff Sessions
does not appoint a second Special
Counsel then we need a new attorney
general judge because you're absolutely
right even if we learn more
horrifying things from the
inspector-general we can't actually
prosecute somebody for those things
because we would need somebody to be
able to bring that case and the
Department of Justice and FBI obviously
won't be bringing a case against
themselves so Jeff Sessions needs to get
rid of this mindset that is a
dereliction of duty and he needs to do
what Congress is called for and appoint
a second Special Counsel to get to the
bottom of this but but Jeff Sessions you
know said he was considering that and
considering investigating certain cases
I don't know whether it was the email
thing or the foundation whatever it was
he kind of gave us all hope a few months
back nothing's happened from that either
the president it doesn't appear that
he's going to get rid of sessions all
right because you know everybody I'm
sure will have a conniption and all his
his senator friends will say it's a
Saturday night massacre so I mean does
America just kind of keep moving as
though it doesn't matter who violates
the law I never underestimate the power
of the American people remember when
there were some people in the
intelligence community who didn't even
want to release the núñez memo but
because tens of thousands of Americans
contacted their members of Congress and
demanded transparency we got it and
that's why the American people need to
back up what Lee Zeldin and many other
members of Congress are fighting for to
get a second special counsel so that
people are held accountable and thrown
in jail for the crimes committed against
the Trump administration during the
transition all right and finally you
know you guys now are really pushing
hard on this do you have meetings with
the instant with the with the Attorney
General I mean have you sat down with
him and said you know maybe you know
over a glass of milk a glass of bourbon
I mean whatever and said come on what is
the problem here I did sit down with the
Attorney General along with Judiciary
Chairman Bob Goodlatte and many others
and I was disappointed that the Attorney
General didn't seem to be very engaged
on any of these issues regarding
existential threats to the Trump
administration he was deferring to a
team that answered to rod Rosen Stein
for goodness sakes and it was Rosen
Stein's very signatures that
reauthorized these wiretaps based on
false information that the Department of
Justice and FBI knew was false
information and so I think we need a
more engage
Attorney General well was the Attorney
General in the company of rod Rosenstein
at the at that point or rots Rosen
Stein's chief of staff as I understand
he usually is
it was the members of the Rosenstein
team that were present and when members
of Congress asked jeff sessions to be
more assertive and take action on a
second Special Counsel he deferred to
staff members I fear judge the Jeff
Sessions has become an employee at the
Department of Justice and he's not
fulfilling his duties as Attorney
General Wow
thank you very much congressman